Welcome to a special
session of the Tata Seminar.
Our class is officially
called Technology Design
and Entrepreneurship Operating
in Emerging Communities.
My name is [? Chintan ?]
[? Veshna, ?] and I co-teach
this course with Dr. Rob
Starr, Dr. Rich Roth,
who should be here somewhere,
and Professor Charlie Fine.
And there are going to be
about 40 graduate Fellows
of our program in
the audience soon.
So on behalf of everybody,
it's a great pleasure
to welcome artist
Olafur Eliasson,
and engineer Frederik Ottesan
to present the seminar.
Thank you.
So first of all, I want to thank
you for choosing to meet us,
given your extremely tight
and short schedule at MIT.
Let me begin by saying a little
bit about the Tata Center
for Technology and Design.
We are focused on creating
technology and systems based
solutions for meeting
the human needs,
particularly in resource
constrained environments.
We started in the fall of
2012, so we are very young,
but we are not small.
We are about 47 graduate
students, about 30 faculty
from 20 different
departments of MIT,
and we're trying to
figure this out together.
So the research
of the Tata Center
falls into about seven areas;
that's energy, health, water,
agriculture, housing
infrastructure,
environmental sustainability,
and entrepreneurship.
Wow that's a lot.
That's a lot, yeah.
And what is particularly
exciting about your visit to
us is that we are imagining
that your journey that you
are taking as a part of
this Little Sun Project
is making you contend
with the challenges
that we are confronting
as a program.
Particularly, we are
focused on understanding
how to identify needs of a
resource constrained community.
How do you work on
solutions in it?
And then most importantly,
how do you disseminate it?
So you can imagine that this
crowd has a number of questions
for you, and I propose that we
run this session by giving you
a chance first to say a
little bit about your work,
and introduce yourself, and then
go right into those questions.
So to get us
started, let me maybe
pose a question that will
lead to your introduction.
Could each of you
tell us what you
would want us to know
about yourself as a person?
How would you describe this
thing called the Little Sun?
I refrain to call it a
product, or a solution,
or an experience,
or what have you.
And how do you see it reflecting
who you are as a person?
That's already happened
one lecture right there.
Go for it.
No, I'm so excited to be here.
Thank you so much.
It's great.
I can very quickly say--
I don't know if I can say
who I would want to be,
but by all modesty I
think I work as an artist,
and what I do is art.
So there was that part.
And then I mean, I grew up in
Denmark with Icelandic parents.
I went to art school
after finishing gymnasium.
And I started art school in
89, two weeks before the wall
came down in Berlin.
My first improvised
trip in my education
was renting a car
driving to Berlin, which
is approximately a seven
hour drive from Copenhagen.
And I've been in Berlin
since 20 years now.
I went back, finished,
studied a bit,
but Berlin became
very important for me.
So being brought up in Denmark,
having a close relationship
with Iceland, where I came from,
spending 20 years in Germany,
sort of toss that together,
and sort of shake it a bit,
you come up with my kind of
psychographic mental map.
So there was that part.
And then I brought a few
pictures of a few artworks,
and that maybe allows me to
say a little bit about how
I arrived to the project.
So I'll do that in a second.
And did you ask me to say?
How does Little
Sun reflect on you?
How does Little Sun--
yeah, I hope that
it does reflect--
I hope that Little
Sun reflects something
of an evolution, something
that is changing,
ongoing, and growing.
And in that sense, it's not
about creating something
static, it's about having
confidence in something
which is more dynamic.
And this of course,
immediately puts you
in a situation
where you constantly
have to think of how does
the past produce the future.
How does our memory somehow
create our expectations?
And for me, it's very much
about combining what I know
with what I would like to do.
And as we all know, it's
one of the great challenges
that we have.
And I certainly have this
that we kind of know so much,
and this is now an institution
of knowledge production
to a great extent.
But the challenge,
as we also know
is, how does one then link
what we know to what we do?
And that might sound very
easy, but for me, Little Sun
very much became a sort of
pivotal point in my life
where what I know actually
channels into a kind of doing
that reflects the knowing.
I, of course,
would like to think
of my artistic work, or
my work as an artist,
as a good example of knowing and
doing, or thinking and acting.
But Little Sun,
by all means, has
I think proven to me
that, with regards
to identification
as you asked, that
is a very important part of it.
Were you going to show some--?
Yeah, why don't
you-- maybe Fredrik
you will introduce
yourself, and I'll
toss in a few pictures
of a few old artworks,
and then we can
take it from there.
We'll come back to this
issue of knowing and doing.
Thank you.
I'm an engineer, and what
I think is really important
is natural curiosity.
So just open your eyes to
the world, and what goes on.
And I think one of the
places where Olafur and I had
common interest was the doing,
and follow your passions.
So right after I
graduated, I felt the need
to feel at home on
this little globe.
And I think the
best way of feeling
at home was to circumnavigate
it in a small boat
because it takes
time, and you get time
to see and to experience,
and developing whatever
you want to do in the world.
It's quite nice to feel at home,
and feel safe anywhere you go.
Then I think it's
strictly important
that when you have the
capabilities of doing something
that you feel is important
that to some extent,
you also have an obligation
to actually do it.
And I didn't make
a solar power lamp
or drag Olafur into making a
solar powered lamp because we
got an idea; the idea
kind of came to us based
on the knowledge that we had,
and listening to the market,
and listening to the demand,
and seeing the very very
limited supply.
I thought it was an
important thing to challenge.
And I also think that
you, in that process,
constantly have to
be curious because we
are in an environment
where we actually
don't know the results.
You also need to
be slightly daring,
and constantly question
what do you actually do.
Is it right, or is it not right?
I don't know, but if we
analyze, and if we're
honest to what we do, and
listen to the environment,
we can come forward to
a reasonable result.
And I think that's a
lot of what I represent
in this is using my technical
expertise in balancing that
to what can we achieve,
and what can we afford,
and how do we actually do that?
And so that was
some of the things
that I found hugely interesting
with venturing into the Little
Sun Project.
At first, it was not my
profession; it was a project.
And we thought it was just a
really interesting project.
It actually came out of another
project that I was doing.
I kind of tend to have a passion
for the slightly impossible.
And so I was working on
a solar powered airplane,
and we actually just finished
the world's first passenger
carrying solar powered airplane.
And a lot of the
discussions Olafur and I
had in the beginning
revolved around the airplane,
until we realized that
maybe the world needed
a lamp slightly more than an
airplane, at least right now.
And so that was how we
got started on working.
So I think that to
take the last question,
so how does Little Sun
actually represent that?
I think without that
natural curiosity,
without that understanding
of the need of talking
to your customers,
without a broad outlook,
it would never have been around.
So it very much embodies
who I feel I am.
And when I realized that
Little Sun embodied who I am,
I was quite surprised to find
that I was a yellow flower.
I saw myself a lot more
like an iPhone, but--
[LAUGHTER]
Working as an
artist nowadays is,
of course, a kind of training
in multiple sort of areas,
such as not only do you
have to make a work of art,
you also have to sort of
facilitate, or make sure
that the interests that the
work of art has in the world
is not mismanaged by the museum.
So you kind of,
as an artist, also
get involved with
running museums,
making sure that they don't
write a press release that
is counterproductive to what
you thought the ad was about.
And frankly speaking,
having worked then
for 20 years as an artist, you
develop a broad set of skills.
Some of which are very
pragmatic in the sense
of making an exhibition
in Venice, where
getting a hammer and
a nail is more or less
impossible in the 11th hour.
And I always say, if you can
make an exhibition in Venice,
you can open up a retail
store in Addis Ababa.
Much easier to work in
off grid rural countries
than it is to be an artist
making an exhibition in Paris.
And I'm actually quite serious.
So this is one aspect
of it, but of course,
within the heart of
the artworks itself,
there is also the
confidence that one
can have a dialogue
with the world, which
has consequences to the world.
And this idea of causality,
meaning that when
I say something, and maybe
it's not a major element,
or it's not going to
change the world a lot,
but yet you feel that you are
interconnected with the world.
And this idea of creativity, or
the way that creativity somehow
performs is really very
much related to the idea
that reality is relative.
So this of course, leads us to
this idea that a work of art
is not the kind of object
standing in the room.
To sort of break
it down to basics,
which is where the artistic
potential is in the object,
the artistic potential
or the creative potential
is in the way that the object
and the context, this being
the world or the time
in which it's happening,
all the space in which it takes
place, and so on, and so forth
is exchanging or
resonating you could say.
So this means that it is
the way that the work of art
is performing in the world
that makes it to work of art.
The work of art itself as it
of itself is only a machine.
Without anybody looking
at it, engaging in it,
or a time in which it's--
a world around it--
it's not really, at least for
me, an interesting work of art.
So I work a lot with
spatial principles systems
in which people engage.
I have studied phenomenology
and psychology with regards
to how do we experience.
The kind of behavioral studies--
what does experiencing actually
mean?
What is the experience economy?
What is counterproductive?
What is productive in this?
So there's a lot of
social scientific material
in this, which taps very
well into communication.
How do you speak
without patronizing
the one you're talking to?
What is non-violent
communication?
How do you exercise a degree
of empathic understanding
of the other?
And what is the
notion of the other?
What is identity?
And so on, and so forth.
So as you know, art,
of course today,
is a kind of incredibly
rich and very resourceful
field, where there
is a lot of studies.
And when we say
something about art,
it is clear that it's a little
bit like saying the word food.
So there's so many Kitchens.
There's so many different types
of looking at food, and so on.
So art is really not--
art is just language.
And I have come to
appreciate this idea.
It's not really so much about
what language you speak,
it's more about what do you
want to say with the language.
So I'm trying to--
I'm so sorry-- I'm trying
to break it very short.
So this is a project.
I have four examples for you.
This is a project-- this
is actually 10 years old,
a little bit of an anniversary
at the Tate Modern Turbine Hall
in London.
So what it is, as you can see,
sort of a sunlike, actually
yellow piece of plastic backlit
with a little bit of haze
in the room, half a circle,
the lower half of a circle,
and then I put a
very large mirror
in the ceiling, which gives
you the sort of impression
that there is a full circle.
But if you look closely, or
if you just look actually
carefully, you can see the
other half is not really there.
It's just a reflection
of the lower half.
But interestingly, what happened
is that people very quickly
started to engage in this
space in various ways,
and it became a
kind of a community
on the floor that started
behaving differently
than what one normally does
in museums, and so on, and so
forth.
So and then, of
course, I could talk
about this in different ways.
But what I think
was particularly
interesting is that there was
no doubt that people were having
an experience with, as
far as I could tell,
was relatively robust.
Some people didn't maybe
like it as much as others,
but generally
speaking, it was clear
that there was an experience.
There's a lot of
things going on.
People started to
behave differently.
Some got more noisy;
some got more quiet.
But what constituted
the space was
this sense of sharing
an experience,
without necessarily
agreeing on what we saw.
So this is an
interesting phenomenon
where I think you can have
a high degree of singularity
in the subjective
experience, but there
was a high degree of plurality
in the sense of sharing.
And as you know,
this is something
that has become
relatively rare in society
because everything
is either polarized,
or it's becoming probabilistic,
or nationalistic, or whatever.
Meaning that things very quickly
become exclusive or excluding.
Meaning that if you don't
agree, you're not welcome.
If you're not the same as
me, or if you look different,
if you have
different background,
and so on, and so forth,
there's a tendency to exclusion.
So as a space, or as an
art institutional system,
it's very interesting that
some institutional systems can
kind of facilitate a
parliamentary, good, democratic
idea about, well, let's see
if we can share something,
without necessarily
having to agree with it.
Let's share and disagree
at the same time.
So this is a discussion
one could go down into.
I think a very
interesting principle
that I've been very
curious to look into,
which is why I've
done works like this.
You can barely see it.
Maybe it's a little
bit of a rainbow,
or it's a small
rainbow, which is
made with water falling,
spotlight, a little bit
like a sort of normal
spotlight in the ceiling.
And as we know, you
need an eye as well
because if there is
nobody in this space,
the question is whether the
rainbow is actually there.
Now, that's a good discussion
between the natural obsessive
natural sciences, or the
kind of phenomenologist
as to what extent is the eye
actually a coproducer here?
But principally speaking,
the object is gone.
It's been dematerialised.
The traditional notion of
what constitutes art is gone.
The subject becomes more active.
My seeing is becoming
the producer.
I become the artist.
The spectator has
become the coproducer.
I as an artist, me, hand
over the responsibility
of the quality of this
project to the people who
come to visit the exhibition.
Meaning that I, as an artist,
I'm only, you know of course,
I kind of write a
narrative, but the reader
is the kind of performer
of the narrative.
And if there is a person next to
me, as we know with a rainbow,
the rainbow that the
person next to me sees
is, by definition, not the same
because the angle of the eye,
and the drop is a different one.
So same phenomena,
but different rainbow.
And we can still
see something where
we constitute the
idea of sameness,
but it is by virtue, as far as
we know, not at all the same.
And so on, and so forth.
So this is the waterfall
in New York five years ago,
I believe 2008, so
six years slowly.
And one could talk
about this sort
of spatial phenomenological
principles,
but what I think is
interesting here,
or one of the things
that was interesting,
to pick one topic again, was
when we see water falling,
we actually also see
how far away it is.
Because, as we know,
water tends to fall
with roughly the same rate--
a little more water does
apparently fall a little
faster-- but, you know,
when you're in a landscape, you
travel to Iceland, no trees,
no cars, no roads.
And you are looking, and you go,
my god, what landscape is this?
Am I on the moon?
I can't really get
a sense of scale.
I wonder if I go down
there, will I be this big,
or will I be that big?
Does it take an hour, or a
day to walk into that valley?
Haven't you been at landscapes
where you just-- it's
somehow if you see a tree in
the area, and if you have a car,
you can kind of tell,
then you look, and then
you see a waterfall.
And you look at the
waterfall, and you
realize the water's
falling very slowly.
Oh it must be a very tall
waterfall, very far away.
Suddenly, the waterfall
introduces a sense of scale,
and obviously it's not the
scale of the landscape that
is interesting, it's the scale
of your body within the context
of the landscape.
So it constitutes
your own presence,
which is why hiking
through a landscape,
and suddenly looking
at a waterfall
can be such a
rewarding experience,
and so on, and so forth.
So depth, perception,
space, and body presence
is one of the things that
I've been very interested in.
And if you look at New York,
where public space has been
privatized, and kind of the
regime of two dimensionality,
depriving social,
let's say, confidence,
which is a big discussion
within public parks and space,
and so on.
It's an interesting
field, and I think
art, of course, is
one of the factors
that can introduce a sense
of, not just [? deafness, ?]
but also a sense of a space
where people can actually meet,
singular, plural, maybe even.
Same principle, rainbow
around circular sculpture,
architecture thing.
You walk around-- if you don't
walk, the color won't change,
as you can see.
Just stand still,
nothing happens.
So if you're not
walking, you're not
activating, so you
again the artist.
I worked for many years
with a number of scientists.
I've always, like
a vampire, sucked
anything I could out of natural
scientists, cosmologists,
physicists, and so on.
I've tried to take advantage
of the methodological successes
that they have
brought to the table.
I, as an artist, aren't
really capable of much,
but believing in that creativity
plays a significant role in how
the world is being shaped.
But the rest of the
stuff I rely on,
incredible other talents
I have, as I grow older,
I have come also to
appreciate them, and respect
the role of, for instance,
the engineer in Frederik's
case, the fact that the
kind of resonating effort
is something that is
very, very valuable.
And when I talk
about effort, I think
I say most specifically
because it's
not about the objective
knowledge that we have.
It's not the sum of
everything we know.
It is the effort that
knowing something gives us.
The effort to actually
push something ahead.
So I have come to
understand, through my art,
that sometimes it's not
understanding a work of art,
or it's not the art work,
but it is the effort
to understand the work of art
that makes me appreciate it.
This is why the effort
of actually trying
to bring an idea into
doing is sometimes
more valuable than the
done idea, or the idea when
it is done.
I think this is a very
interesting argument
because very often we have
people who have great ideas.
My students at the University
in Berlin, they say,
I have made an
amazing work of art.
Let me just explain it to you.
It's an idea.
It goes like this.
Isn't that a great work of art?
And I say, no, no, no.
It's an idea about a potentially
interesting work of art,
but why don't you try to
put some effort into it,
and see if it
actually translates
into something interesting?
Because once you
start doing that,
you will see two
things happening.
First of all, it changes.
Secondly, the effort is not
as easy as one should think.
The effort is actually
really hard work, complex.
You have to have
engineers on board.
And then they motivate
you, but they also kind of
make it very difficult
because they also
bring in sort of data that is
just not what you had expected.
I think you do that too.
[LAUGHTER]
So I was thinking
about what's in common
about art and engineering?
And one of the things that
interestingly occurred to me
was that this whole
idea of ideas to action,
which is the title of this
session, or Menz et Manos,
which is the model of
MIT, mind and hands,
is where these two
disciplines may come together.
So here's my question.
What, to you, comes in
between an idea and action,
and is this where art and
engineering, or disciplines
come together?
Is this where they
actually differ
so that something
interesting can
come from their interaction?
How do you think about that?
I think a lot about that.
And I think one
of the things that
is in between having an idea,
and actually doing something
actually, to a
lesser extent, has
to do with the
choice of material,
then it has to do with the
degree of self-confidence.
So surprisingly, the kind of
trust you have in yourself,
with regards to
stepping from the idea
into giving it language, is
actually a much different--
it's quite adventurous to
have an idea, then take a pen,
and then make a drawing.
It's like an unbelievably
rich moment when you
start to give the idea shape.
One can even go
backwards a little bit.
So where did the idea come from?
And sometimes, if you don't
know exactly what to draw--
in my case, it can
sort of plays off you
going back, wow,
this idea really
came out of that feeling.
Before it was language because
I can speak about my idea.
It actually was a sort
of non-verbal sort
of state of something.
And this was, to some
extent, intuitive.
I don't know if I could
barely even think about it,
but I had the feeling.
And this is a lovely state.
I'm sorry to kind of get
more and more vague here,
but let's just wander down
this path a little bit.
So sometimes we
also must appreciate
we have a feeling, which has
not yet found a language yet.
It's incredible, and
we should nurture it.
So where does this come from?
Maybe it is a kind
of micro trauma.
So 10 years ago, I
was in a situation.
Something happened, and it
kind of left an imprint,
like a footprint in--
so depending on where, and
how we use our language--
in my soul, I could say.
So this footprint--
and then I realized,
10 years later, I'm going
there, oh interesting.
That just stayed with
me, that footprint.
And now, I can add a word to it.
I can feel this.
Let me just go back, and
visit that footprint.
What was the circumstances?
What inspired me?
Why was I-- a micro trauma
can be both good and bad,
and it's so very complex.
So there is something there.
And we can exercise
this a little bit
as I think one should
not hesitate to do.
So see where do I get
my inspiration from.
We have to seek the
kind of the places
where inspiration is brought
to us, whether it's preverbal
or not.
We can also think about that.
Let's think of 10
years from now,
where we are sitting
somewhere else,
and we're going to look
back at this classroom
where we're sitting now.
What do we think
is needed in order
to make this moment
of such a quality
that our footprint is taken
with us into 10 years from now?
From now, I can sort of send
a greeting into the future.
I say hi to myself.
And say, oh this is now,
we have to say something.
And this means that we have
to take the moment serious.
We have to treasure this
incredibly important moment
because maybe we, right
now, are about to do
something significant.
So I'm just saying
the idea from thinking
to doing is, especially
at its beginning,
incredibly complex
and wonderful.
So from there then, of
course, very quickly, it also
has to do with a certain
talent with regards
to rationalizing the steps.
Should it be a tabletop
experimental process?
Should it be a spatial?
Should it be a big
laboratory at MIT?
Do I need a 100 people team,
or just need one person?
So all these sort of
methodological questions that.
And I think this, of course,
depends, and has a lot
to do with what idea, but
one thing that I think
is very important
is that you are--
and then I think you should talk
about it for a little bit also.
I think for one, you are
on the way from the idea,
and in my case, a work of art.
But it could really be anything.
So you're on it, but
you're only halfway there,
and oh my God, this is never
ever going to be a work of art.
And then you're kind of stuck.
And there's a
certain point where
also talking to a
natural scientist
just won't help you because
you know it's your choice.
I said, oh you can't ask
somebody to solve it for you.
So this is, I think, an
interesting moment also
in the process because
the solution is not
in-- the solution is not
looking at the problem,
but it is looking at the
world in which the problem is
located.
So sometimes, the making
sense of a problem
lies in seeing the problem in
the context of the world, which
brings you from asking
how to asking why.
So generally speaking,
we go from thinking
to doing as asking how.
It's going to be red.
It's going to be wood.
I'm going to make it so tall.
And so there's all this house.
And then at some point, you
just run short of-- it's
just like kind of you've driven
yourself into the desert.
Then you start
wondering, well, why?
And then you have
a new momentum.
Oh now I know why.
Of course, then well,
maybe I shouldn't have
made it red in the first place.
Maybe it should be yellow.
So these are, in a very abstract
sense, I think the kind of,
and as you can tell, the
kind of methodology where
the trust plays a major role.
Do I have confidence
in making a choice?
And do I have confidence,
and even doing
it looking at the world?
And see how the world feeds
you to make the choice,
and how the choice
also impacts the world.
I call that touching.
You touch the world.
You hold hands with
the sun, or you
are being touched by the world.
You are interconnected.
I think one of the
things you mentioned
that, in this
practice as an artist,
you were using engineers, and
physicists, and mathematicians.
As I'm not an artist,
I'm an engineer,
I could also see
that, as an engineer,
I think it could be really
beneficial to use an artist.
And that's kind of
what I came about.
Because I started this
solar powered lamp idea,
and it came to my mind that
I wanted to make an impact.
And I looked in the marketplace,
and I didn't-- it's not
an invention in any way.
Solar powered lamps has
been around for a while.
And how could we then
make a real impact?
And what were the drivers in
buying products like this,
or artworks like this?
And I realized looking
into the marketplace,
there was absolutely no
product in the market that
inspired any kind of happiness,
or any kind of beauty,
or any kind of emotions.
Human beings are
hugely emotional.
And then I kind of looked
back at my history,
and my education, and learning.
It there's just a blank page.
I never learned anything about
designing $0.35 of plastic
into giving any
kind of emotions.
I just couldn't do it.
I could sit and draw forever.
I could look at my study books.
I had not learned
how do I put emotions
into a piece of plastic.
So I'm going, I can't do this.
I could make squares,
and I could make rounds.
I could calculate the volumes
in squares and rounds,
and stuff like that, but it
just didn't change the picture.
So that's where kind
of, of course, I
look at Olafur because
very, very few people are
capable of putting a huge
amount of emotions into a mold,
and reproduce their emotions
a million times at no cost.
So I think, as
engineers, there's
a huge opportunity in looking
into production of emotions,
and that's where the artwork
comes into the picture.
So that a little bit underlines
the collaboration of how
we work, and the necessity.
When you were talking about
your other art projects,
you talked a lot about
the idea of trying
to make part of the art the
experience of the people that
observe art.
So as you're thinking about the
design process for Little Sun,
who is it that is
experiencing this art,
and what was the experience
that you wanted them to have?
We started working
with the Little Sun,
and we were spending some
time in Ethiopia testing it.
And so, for instance, we
went to see a German version
of what is called USAID.
You know, kind of
engineers working locally,
and really talented
people, and so on, it's
called [? GT7 ?] in Germany.
And we were sitting there,
and they said, oh just
make sure it just bloody works.
Who cares about the sun?
This is Africa.
So it's typically a sort of a
kind of neocolonial attitude,
condescending and so on.
We kind of couldn't see it even.
We were like, oh yeah,
yeah, yeah, kind of.
This was a few years ago now.
And then Frederik went out,
and drove to south of Ethiopia.
And then he came back in the
evening, or the next day,
and he said, you
know, what's so funny?
We had something which looked
a little bit like an ice hockey
puck.
It's like really
sort of practical.
You could toss it
around, nothing happens,
so totally unemotional.
And then he said,
Frederik, well you
know, I was showing some young
girls, sort of on the way
home from school
I guess, the lamp,
and they said, oh
well, interesting lamp,
but the string is really nice.
And then Frederik took out his
iPhone, and he wrote that down,
and then they said, the
iPhone is really amazing.
And I was like, oh, we're
doing something wrong.
And obviously, it just
dawned on me very quickly.
My god, it was so typical to
think that functionality alone
will do.
So typically, engineers to
think that they can somehow
tell, or speak on
behalf of other people.
No offense, but you
know what I mean.
So the kind of
first learning curve
with regards to the design
was as Frederik actually
pointed out.
Well, of course,
the success lays
in the ability to touch each
other, or to be touched.
And this is interesting
because this everybody shares.
It's not about the kind
of resourceful North,
and the resourceless South.
It just becomes about the
desires we have in life.
So I want to be happy.
That's it.
I want to have beautiful
stuff around me, relatively
beautiful.
I just like-- I just want
a certain amount of luxury
in my life because it just makes
me happier, simple as that.
So the design very quickly
became about also saying, well,
this project is about the
same needs everywhere.
It's not like only a problem
when you're in off-grid x-area,
where there's no
access to energy.
It's kind of a global problem
that a part of the world
is totally disconnected
from power, disregarding
the health, the
kind of, you know,
the climate, the educational,
all the sort of surrounding
aspects.
So the driving
process really started
with saying, well, let's just
make a lamp that everybody
thinks is beautiful.
I think I'll rephrase that a
little bit because the truth
is, to answer your
question, we did
have what you would consider
as a focus group in Hawassa,
a small town South of
Addis Ababa, Ethiopia.
And we did also look at the
demographics of Ethiopia
because that was
our starting point.
And looking at that, you
realize that the population
is on average below 16.
So you need to make a product
that speaks incredibly well
to children.
And the people buying products
for the children is mothers.
So designing
something that would
fall in the taste of
women and children,
then you cover about
80% of your market.
And with any kind
of product, it's
quite nice to know
that you cover
a certain amount of the market.
And so the lamp is built
in a direct dialogue
with those women and
children in Hawassa.
And as all of us said, we
were going back and forth
between Berlin and Addis
quite a couple of times,
realizing that the first
prototypes we made just
didn't work.
Not that they didn't
work technically--
and when we were showing
the products in the market,
and talking about the
products in the market,
they were very, very
sellable because we
were able to communicate
the upside of the product--
but as soon as we laid
the product by itself,
in an open market, on a
little kiosk or something,
it wouldn't move because it
didn't communicate by itself.
So nothing happened.
And I think that's
very much in line
with what we see on the
other products in the market.
They don't communicate, and
that means they're not sellable.
Because our customers,
they don't care about LEDs.
They can't judge it.
They don't care about
battery qualities
because they can't judge it.
They don't care about
solar panel output
because it doesn't
make any sense to them.
So they care about emotions.
They need something
that they will pick up
because they think it's nice,
or beautiful, or interesting,
or emotional because
that's how we are.
So going back and forth a
couple of times, realizing
that we didn't have
the right product,
we were looking at
photos, I think--
who was in charge of this thing?
I'll just move to a photo
I can quickly browse.
Yeah, can you take
the photo of me
in the street with the girls?
Because one of the things
that is really interesting
learning is understanding
who your customers are,
and what they stand for.
And our customers,
they're romantic.
Their patterns, their colors,
the layers, the flowers,
they're by no means minimalists.
And that you have to understand,
and that you have to address.
And so the next
time we came back.
So we looked at that
picture, and realized
that that was the case, and
what we were doing wrong.
And we went Addis asking
completely different things
that we've done at
any other point.
So we'd start asking,
how does prosperity look?
How does beauty look?
What is your favorite color?
That kind of questions we
would ask our customer group.
And as Olfaf was telling
for physical bodies,
then turn those questions
into something that looked
somewhat similar to this.
It's also about the story.
So I think you
detailed what I said.
It wasn't really different
from what I said.
That degree of the
detail of the design
process, and not forgetting
there is a practical side,
we also wanted to compete
with the oil industry.
So there's a bit, sort of,
money, monetary, financial.
But still, there
was also this story,
and the design is obviously
the relationship with the lamp,
as much as the kind of
actual tangible feeling of it
in your hand.
So the story, at a
very early stage,
that I was with an elderly
woman, and I said to her,
I have to explain it, and
then it's also a work of art.
And she looked at me, she said,
what do you mean a work of art?
And I said, well,
it's a work of art.
And this was in Addis Ababa.
And she looked at me, and
says, so she said to me,
like in the church?
And then I looked at her,
and I didn't see that coming.
And then I said, yes,
exactly like in the church.
Then she looked, and said,
oh but that's amazing.
So you see sometimes this idea
that something nonfunctional
carries you much further.
And obviously, it
still has to work,
and has to compete with a
certain price benchmark,
and so on.
And this is where this idea of
combining this idea of power--
I have five hours of
sunlight in my hand.
I'm holding hands with the sun.
When I charge it,
I charge myself.
The idea of resources
being, on one side,
the kind of measurable
amount of sunlight
that you have in your
battery, and sort of
suggest that there is a
relationship between that,
and how you feel.
You are charging yourself.
You are becoming resourceful.
That became a kind of
design driver with regards
to understanding
what is our message.
How do we reach out
in a way that is--
productive sounds
so quantifiable--
but reach out in a
way which actually
is confidence building.
When you say that
you have a sun--
you have the power of
the sun in your hand,
and then when I'm
thinking that, oh but it
has this solar
panel, and batteries,
and there's a casing,
and there's a LED.
I mean, I understand it.
We have a really funny
picture of a sign
because we didn't have marketing
material in the beginning,
we just had lamps.
And then we started testing out
selling these lamps at kiosks,
and they created marketing
material themselves.
So a really nice one, a
big picture, and our logo,
and it says, no batteries,
no electricity, only sun.
It's just completely wrong,
but that's the perception.
So I think you, as
an engineer, have
to understand that a
lot of your customers,
at least in this market, have
a very different perception
of technology than you do.
I did a lot of road trips in
Ethiopia in the beginning,
and I talk to our
focus group, and one
of the questions I came
about quite frequently was,
is it dangerous to wear it?
And that surprised
me quite a lot
because I couldn't
understand it.
And another question I
got that really showed me
our customer group's
understanding of technology
was, will it work
without the strap?
And to you and me, that seems
like a quite odd question,
but if technology is pretty
distant from what you do,
it's a perfectly valid question.
And it just shows you how far
away LEDs and batteries are,
if you can think that
the lamp will not
work without the strap.
Hello, I'm a graduate
student of the MIT Media Lab,
and I'm also an artist.
My question is based on the
consumer feedback, and the way
that people are using it, what
is the future of the Little Sun
Project?
You plan to design another one?
Oh yeah.
So of course, we have
like so many plans.
[LAUGHTER]
But I think one
very clear ambition
is to succeed in scale.
I mean, now we have--
we feel we're so we're
so excited, and proud,
and all of that.
We have kind of managed
to bring about--
what is it, 130?
250,000 lamps.
We have 250,000 now.
So and that has-- if they are
all out there, and working,
and so on, we have
already tossed a few--
we have reduced the
sales of petroleum.
It's not a lot, but
you know, considering.
So soon we can sort of
start trade carbon sort of.
Now so the idea is obviously
that every fifth person
in the world doesn't
have access to energy.
And this is really
the perspective.
And we are already--
we are close to finishing
a mobile phone charger.
We have worked and worked
again on our business model.
We are close to breaking
a kind of investment
into our little company here.
And so there's a number
of things going on.
The business model
is basically based
on selling at a higher price
in places where there is power,
and then we sell it at a lower
price where there is no power.
But we are market driven.
It's not an aid project.
It's not a, sort of, it's
supposed to build up--
and that's a whole field
of itself, microeconomics.
To be at the bottom of pyramid
economical infrastructure,
and build up in
the retail system.
The whole idea of retailing
this is a whole field of itself.
We have a little
task force in Berlin,
where people are actually
being paid from the money being
generated by this.
10 people are working now, and
a few people, and hopefully
more and more people are
working in rural places, where
there's no access to energy.
So we're very ambitious.
Hi.
My name's Alana, and I'm a
first year graduate student here
at MIT Sloan.
And you sold this product
across different geographies,
and so I'd like to
know a little bit more
about how you've adapted your
messaging, or your marketing
strategy, or your
dissemination to adapt
to different geographies
and cultures.
I think that's a tough one.
I don't think
we're that far yet.
So the truth is that we actually
haven't picked our markets
very strategically.
The markets kind
of picked us up.
When we started out, we knew
that, in order to succeed,
we needed to focus, and then
learn from that experience,
and spread that.
But we are also
about communication,
and it is a global challenge.
And in a political world,
having a global challenge,
and a global
communication platform,
and only addressing the
challenge in one market,
it doesn't work that well.
And Olafur and I are also both
incredibly bad at saying no.
So when people ask
us to do something,
we tend to say yes, at
least from time to time.
So a lot of the time, and
in business, and in markets,
and selling is also about
meeting the right people
at the right time.
So when we have felt
that somebody came along
in a specific market wanted
to do something with this,
we've said yes some times,
perhaps too many times.
And that means we
actually haven't
made our strategic marketing
fit a specific market.
We only have one
way of doing it,
and we do the same in
Ethiopia, and Senegal,
and Rwanda, Uganda,
Nairobi, the whole thing.
And of course, that's not right.
And we also know that, even
though the lamp is designed
for Ethiopia, had the
design been made for Uganda,
it would have been
different because that's
how the nature is.
So we also know that,
of course, there's
a need for different marketing
to optimize your sale.
But right now, we are at a
point where we are really
happy that we're just selling.
To get into the optimization
of selling, we haven't done.
And I also think in that
whole marketing question,
there's a really
interesting observation.
Do you really need to market,
and why do you do marketing?
You normally tend to do
marketing, at least in the US,
if you want to sell products
that people don't want.
So you need to tell them
to want the products.
We don't need to do that
because our customers,
they want the product.
So the biggest
challenge that has
nothing to do with
Little Sun-- the biggest
challenge in solar devices
in Africa is delivery.
It's not designing.
It's not producing.
It's not selling.
It's delivery.
So it's the supply chain
is actually the biggest
challenge for all of us.
And we meet once a year at
conferences, and exchange
knowledge, and it's the
same across the board.
Everybody agrees that that is
actually the real challenge.
D.light is the biggest player
on the solar appliance market.
And you tend to think
they do radio marketing.
So they're the only ones
that right now have a budget
to do radio marketing, and
it's fantastic for everybody.
Because the customers, they
see a solar powered lamp,
and to them that's a
d.light because d.light
is so strong in the marketing.
So they created the Walkman,
and when people bought a Walkman
in the 80s, they didn't
care if it came from Sony,
or somebody else, it
was still a Walkman.
And so a d.light is just
a solar powered lamp,
so it benefits everybody.
I think you did
answer my question.
Thank you.
I wanted to add
something with regard
to the whole communication also
has to do with the awareness,
and what footprint do
we then leave in people.
And the awareness building
really is both on a--
a child who grows up with this
reading every night in bed.
How does that child make
a decision with regards
to energy, when that
child is grown up,
and has to build a house,
and make a choice for energy?
So there's that story.
There's also the general
policy making, and the need
to address systems and
solutions, and so on.
And one of the
challenges I think
is, again as we spoke
about, thinking and doing.
And so I worked with
on a few occasions
with Little Sun and our team,
and for like with on how
to communicate the
lamp in other ways
than the traditional marketing.
And obviously, on a large
scale, it doesn't work.
This is a picture of a project
that we are doing occasionally,
and I think we are
now doing it on the--
what is it called, Casilla?
Here in America,
the music festival?
Coachella.
So Coachella, they love
us, and we love them.
So it's a happy marriage.
And so they ask, why
don't you come and do
some sort of Little Sun stuff?
So this is in a way.
And we could do it also--
we're trying to build
a music festival,
a sort of block party in Addis
Ababa, and this sort of thing.
So the idea is that
you make a graffiti,
or a drawing with a lamp.
And interestingly, I
think this idea of motion
is about the difference
between just thinking about, oh
this is really interesting.
You might touch it.
It's a good beginning.
But if you start to dance,
then you are, one could say,
you are a little
bit traumatized.
You know what I mean
when I said before
that you kind of have memory?
Because then you go
home, and you go,
oh yeah that was that lamp.
You know, now I
know how it feels.
So you store this
story through motion.
And as we know from, and that
apparently came from MIT,
if you make gymnastics
by learning mathematics,
you're much more likely
to remember it long term.
You know, so all
the kind of stories
of knowledge and movement,
and it's a big mistake
that you're all sitting
down like this with regards
to what we say.
It's simply not going to be--
you should be
jumping up and down.
So the point-- maybe you
can turn on the globe.
So this photo, as I said,
is me trying to draw,
and unsuccessfully
trying to write something
in front of a sort of
stop motion camera, which
captures the light.
But essentially,
the project brings
the Coachella, for
instance, and we
have done it again and again.
It then sends that picture
onto an online planet,
and this planet is, which is
then built. But so you see,
so it's like kind
of building a sun.
So essentially, this
is, at some point,
going to be so full that
it's just because the sun.
When you Zoom into it,
you'll see all the signatures
of the people, and the
signatures are kind of a dance.
So it's just a little
marketing project,
which is about
awareness building,
and creating a sense of
community, and sharing the sun,
and--
so there is plenty of small
little town projects like this,
which reach out into
what we call social media
type of Twitter friendly stuff.
But it also addresses the fact,
well, understanding energy
is not so easy because
energy is very abstract,
except for incredible
people like you here at MIT.
But generally speaking, energy
is something very difficult.
It's very difficult to
understand the climate crisis.
Oh my God, you know,
it's so intangible.
Hi.
My name is Bertha.
I'm a PhD student
doing bar electronics.
My question is more towards
the merging of the two markets.
So you're developing this
product for the developing
world, people without
access to electricity,
and a lot of the marketing, and
the buzz that you're creating
is in the developed world,
with the social media
platforms and exhibitions.
So in your product,
how important
is that, and is that how most
of the money and the buzz
is being generated?
And just leading on
to that, how important
do you think, in general, kind
of trying to merge these two
markets is, rather
than thinking of this
as the thing that the developing
world as the consumers,
and getting money from
the developed world?
I think one of the good things,
with especially social media,
is social media, they don't
have a Facebook for Africa,
and Facebook for
the United States.
They only have a Facebook.
So when you use social
media, it works equally well
on all our markets.
And I think if we
had tons of money,
and wanted to market the Little
Sun really heavily in Nigeria,
the most effective
thing would probably
be a huge big poster on
Fifth Avenue in New York.
And so most people don't realize
that the globe is unbelievably
small, and that we
all see the same,
and that we all
aspire for the same.
So when we do a
big thing in Milan,
that's hugely
important in Zimbabwe.
And we know that.
So we have people in
small stores in Zimbabwe
saying that it is so fantastic
that we do stuff in Milan.
So yeah, I can add to that.
A good example is a Renaissance
is a shopping mall in Milan
in front of the Duomo, the
most expensive shopping
mall for the kind of-- so
they gave us the Christmas
windows Little Sun Project,
that project, stuff like that.
So very interestingly,
we were doing
a pilot kiosk in Addis Ababa.
Assefa-- maybe you can
put Assefa on there.
It's the one with the spread.
So Assefa-- we said, ah you know
Christmas and Milan, we'll go,
and then we do a Christmas
party, a Little Sun Christmas
party.
Then Assefa says, oh amazing.
Oh I love Milan.
Milan is amazing.
I love Milan.
I'm selling something;
Milan is selling something.
We're in the same boat.
It's great.
I'm going to go.
That's Assefa.
So Assefa says, I'm going to
go to Milan for the Christmas
party, but the truth is
he's not because he's
selling cigarettes
out of the packs,
and chewing gum one
piece at a time.
But he was like so into
the party, totally loved
it, easy going, easy peasy.
Then we are in Milan
at the Christmas party,
doing a little bit of
sort of preparation,
and so on, communication prep
with the team, the sales team,
and so on, and so forth.
And then, of course, everybody
goes, oh Assefa, the guy,
we're going to help us, so
we will party for Assefa.
So the idea that they
were partying with Assefa
was really not present.
So the distance from
Addis Ababa to Milan
is much shorter than from
Milan to Addis Ababa.
So the mindset is
very interesting.
The mindset is, with
regards to the matter,
there's a huge difference
in the conception,
the kind of interpretation
of the African market
from the kind of northern.
And normally, I would always say
we are five years behind what
is actually going on.
And of course, it's a
little more complex.
And of course, it is--
I mean we have trained to
stop saying underdeveloped,
developing, developed.
We've just trained
to stop saying it
because it's so
counterproductive.
When you are in Addis
Ababa, and say, oh you're
sort of underdeveloped,
Assefa goes,
what do you mean
it's underdeveloped?
It's not undeveloped.
It's a very good kiosk.
So it's been a learning curve.
And I think the truth
is we should also not
be afraid of saying
whether sometimes it
is bloody underdeveloped.
You know, girls
don't go to school.
That is underdeveloped.
And to find a balance, and sort
of a way of addressing this
without being excluded, or
exclusive, or something.
It's a complex challenge.
But by all means, a
lot of the challenges
are very much in the
northern hemisphere,
and much to a much
lesser extent,
in the southern hemisphere.
I think now, I just remembered
a funny story with regards
to marketing and technology.
I think now that we
are here in Teta.
And engineering,
so you're all aware
that you made the
Nano a phenomenal car
from an engineering perspective.
I mean, they made an
achievement that no car company
had made so far.
They marketed the cheapest
car in the world, which
is an astonishing achievement.
But who wants that?
Do you think it
became a success?
No, it did not.
Nobody wants to have the
cheapest car in the world.
Now they're repositioning
it with huge costs.
So if you make
something-- and this,
right now, is the cheapest solar
powered lamp on the market.
So going back to d.light, their
cheapest version is called S1,
and that retails in Uganda
between $12 and $14.
We retail in Uganda
between $10 and $12,
which is slightly below.
We are the cheapest
lamp on the market.
We also think we're
the most beautiful.
Do we ever tell anybody
that we are the cheapest
lamp on the market?
Of course not.
We tell them that we are
the most beautiful lamp
on the market because we think
that's what our customers want.
So that's, again, how
do you communicate?
And that communication
translates very well globally.
I was in a class a little
while ago, and it's D-Lab.
I don't know if
you've heard of it.
They do a lot of products
in countries, like Africa,
and South America, and so forth.
And one of the things
I had asked them about
was the fact that
there's a million
and seven different
kinds of solar lamps,
and why despite that, there
still seems to be this problem.
One of the things they
brought up was the Little Sun,
and they said, that in
their experience traveling,
it was seen more as a toy
than an actual appliance.
Now, I don't know
if that's actually
a good thing or a bad thing
because kids are still
using it, but what are
your thoughts on that?
I think that's a plus.
So if you know that
your consumer group is
below 16, and perceiving it as
a toy, then you hit your market.
I also think when they say
they perceive it as a toy,
it's probably that it's very
optimistic, and slightly naive.
And children and toys
tend to be that way.
I haven't experienced
anybody not liking it,
and not smiling
when they saw it.
So one thing is that you
perceive it as a toy,
but you quickly
realize that it works.
The main downside
on kerosene lantern,
which is a bio-fuel
lantern light
is the health issues,
especially for the ones
who sits right next to
the kerosene lantern.
A single wick kerosene lantern,
if you sit within a meter
distance, it's the
equivalent in two hours
to smoking 40 cigarettes.
And this means, if
you are a child doing
your homework, which
is the most exposed
in the household because they
literally sit-in, like you
know, they burn their
front hair on the kerosene
because they sit with a lamp,
and the kerosene, and the book.
So this means that the kind
of major instant impact
is a health impact.
The more long term impact is
hopefully generating a cheaper
chain of economy, bringing
a little more resources
to the families simply
because they are buying,
over the lifespan
of three years--
which is the rechargeable
batteries in this--
that will allow for a
little bit extra money
to maybe keep one
child out of labor,
and put that one child
into school maybe.
And so there is a
number of benefits,
but they all somehow
involves children.
Typically, the people
in the household,
as far as we have
come to understand,
who spent money on this type
of material is also the mother.
Basically, in our system, the
father's out of the equation.
He just would never
buy a solar lantern.
So this is a bit of a
follow up on their behavior.
So seeing as the purpose
of the Little Sun
is to actually
have an experience
kind of with the
individual that's using it,
what has been your
follow up with people
who have purchased this?
Have you seen them
using it as a toy?
Do literacy in regions
increase with this?
I guess have you measured
some kind of behavior trends
on the other side?
We don't have this.
We just a small
start up, so we don't
have the capabilities of
going out and measuring
the results of the Little Sun.
We rely on the World Bank
and Lighting Africa studies
on what happens in
environments where you
introduce solar powered light.
And those studies always
show that you actually
have an increase in studying
hours, and also an increase
in education
learning on that one.
But it's not a Little
Sun thing, it's
a solar powered lamp thing.
And we also, I think we
learned a little bit-- oh
I'm getting louder and
louder, or is that just me?
Hey.
So what is so important--
but what we also see is
actually it's hard to--
we should be a
little bit careful
to predict too much because we
were with a-- you were with a,
I believe, an
elderly gentleman who
was going to go out
every morning, 4
o'clock in the morning,
to milk the cow.
And you said, as I said
to him, oh why don't you
use the Little Sun?
It's about 4:00 in the
morning; it's dark.
He said, no, no,
I've been doing that
in darkness for 40 years or so.
I kind of know how that goes.
But you know, now I've
become a little older,
what I'm afraid of
now is actually,
when I go to the
toilet by night--
which he didn't want
to talk about really--
I'm afraid of falling,
and if I break a hip,
my family falls apart.
So it was unpredictable
the kind of use.
And of course, we
have seen some people
who just sort of use
it to kind of party,
or just sort of have fun.
Because we are so, oh you
have to educate the children,
but then the children's
just kind of playing around
with it as a toy.
Kind of like not doing
their homework, damn it.
So some of it also has to
do with that it's just--
there's a certain limit to
how to define the success.
I wonder why do we need an
artist in order to solve this,
or to find the answer
for these problems?
And of course, I
know and all we know
that you are not working alone.
You work with a group.
But why not an economist,
an engineer, an architect,
a sociologist, or a politician?
That's a good question.
I actually also don't
know whether I am actually
an artist in that way.
I don't, to be honest,
think of myself as an artist
in order to do something.
I do think of me as a
part of a civic system,
and being a contributor,
or a participant,
or coproducer of a civic system.
I see that I bring
in my skill set,
but I actually don't think
you need an artist at all,
to be honest.
And as we know, there is
plenty of success stories
in the world, sadly, where
there is no artist involved.
So I don't think one
can say by definition--
I do think, though, that--
I could not end it there.
So I do think that art, frankly
speaking, it is, especially
today, as success
is increasingly
being defined by
quantifiable measures,
the definition of success is
becoming narrower and narrower.
If it's not
sellable, measurable,
if you don't become rich,
it's probably not a success.
And sadly, a lot of
soft skill successes,
unpredictable or
soft successes are
kind of falling off the cliff in
this deep, competitive, market
driven, arrogant, probabilistic
sort of world we live in.
The lack of interdependence,
the lack of altruistic effort,
and all of that is
simply kind of-- you
don't have a politician
who comes around
to say, well, as long as the
art museum shows good art,
I'm happy.
They would always say,
well, if it doesn't
have 200,000 people
a year, probably
it's then not a good art museum.
Of course, we all know
that art has nothing
to do with the amount of
people, but the politicians just
won't get elected.
So this means, by all means--
this is not artist, but
there is a lot of things
that I would argue we need
to start to treasure what
creativity is capable of.
And artists are certainly not
the only ones who are creative.
We argue all of
[INAUDIBLE],, I mean.
But just generally speaking,
we should really just
be very careful.
And this is why I would
suggest if now we're
sort of in an engineering,
under your great guidance,
and then into
engineering environment,
I really encourage
and suggest that you
would reach out, and ask
artists, and really ask
creative people.
And that might slow you down.
It might take you on a detour.
It might actually pose
a problem that you
think is not important.
But generally speaking, I
really think it's worth it.
You're also suggesting that
when we run our conference
on our work, we invite a very
diverse audience, including
artists, to just listen
to what they have to say.
Yes, I mean, as much as
I can celebrate artists,
there's no doubt that artists
are elitist, arrogant.
Everything that I've been
talking about in society,
that happens in art too, right?
In museums, they're
sort of single minded,
snobbish, like super
[? wide. ?] So there's so much
problems in art, and the
solution is obviously a coming
together from all sides.
And I can tell you
that engineers are not
that way, certainly not
in this institution.
[LAUGHTER]
Let's go to the next question.
It comes from
Professor [? Shaya. ?]
Some people in this
audience have come here
from all the way from Mumbai.
Yeah, I have two questions.
One is a small question,
and the next question
is a larger question.
The small question is what
is the battery life in this?
2 and 1/2 years.
2 and 1/2 years is
the short reply.
And the product life
is about 10 years?
That would be quite fair to say.
Yes.
Right.
OK.
So now the larger
question is as follows.
You're not like having
visited and surveyed
the areas in Africa, and
developing countries--
I'm glad you didn't call it
an underdeveloped country
and developing country.
So if you see the
development goals,
one sees that any product
that sort of helps directly
in poverty reduction
makes a larger impact.
So your company like Little
Sun, if it makes success,
and I'm sure it will, all
the best for your product,
but what would be,
based on your survey,
and visits to the
African countries,
and other developing
countries, what
could be a product
that would sort of help
in the sort of
livelihood opportunities,
so that poverty is
reduced, and some
of the millennium development
goals are achieved?
Did you get my question?
You said what product--
Which product would--
But I certainly do think
that Little Sun participated
in exactly that.
We see in the environments
that when you buy a Little Sun,
you're not spending
money, you're
saving money because you
free up approximately 90%
of your current expenditure on
kerosene, or oil, or paraffin,
candles, whatever you do.
So there is a cost
saving that you
could spend for something else.
You also see people making
a profit selling them.
So as soon as the lamp
reaches our market,
there's a normal
profit margin in it
for everybody that moves
towards the customer.
They make a profit.
So that's profit
generated in that region.
You have better
education, learning.
As I said before, that
generates in turn,
it'll probably take 10-15 years,
more profit, and more self
esteem, and understanding.
So there's a whole
array of things
that happens when you introduce
small products like this.
And that is, again, the same
with all similar products.
We see a world of
interconnectivity.
We see everybody in the
world with a cell phone.
So giving people energy,
I mean subsidizing light,
is relatively easy.
So you could burn a little
bit of oil, or whatever
you want to get light,
but it's pretty hard
to charge your cell
phone with a candle.
So subsidizing the
energy needed to supply
energy for a smartphone,
or an iPhone,
or that kind of appliances,
that's a natural next step.
And these products are
coming out everywhere.
I mean, we're seeing
smartphones just
growing in the African market,
and in the Indian market,
tremendously.
Today, there is way more
cell phones in Africa
than in Europe.
Right now, Europe is slightly
ahead on the smartphone market,
but that will only
last maybe two years.
So these are coming,
and that again,
connects us all
completely, going back
to the social media thing.
So delivering the
energy to do that--
and we are seeing education
platforms going out,
and that kind of media
as well creating jobs.
I mean, that really means that
you could live in a rural area,
anywhere in the world,
delivering software
to General Electrics,
just to give an example.
Because we will be able
to work-- the reason
they can't do that today
is because they don't have
the computer, and they
don't have the energy
to run the computer.
Right now, in India, I could
buy a little laptop, $38,
which is actually a sum
that most of our customers
could come up with,
if they really wanted.
But right now, they
can't run it because they
don't have the internet.
But if we can deliver
autonomous energy,
and small digital
devices, then the world
will truly come together.
And I certainly
think that will help
a lot of the millennium goals.
The Little Sun project
feels like a side project.
If you're shaping
shared experiences
in art spaces for people
to participate in,
this feels like a much more
personal or small scale
experience.
And for you, it also seems
very different from work
that you've done before.
So how would you
say that this is
going to influence your
work going forward,
and are the two kinds
of projects going
to converge at some point?
And do you think that
it's a path that you
would like to continue along?
There are several components
in the Little Sun Project
that are different
from my other work,
but there is also a lot
that is overlapping.
The whole idea about questioning
or investigating self-esteem.
The idea of feeling
resourceful, but also
the idea of feeling
interconnected,
the idea of sharing a project,
participating in a project.
This lends itself very well to
online exchange of information.
We have a lot of people who
through Facebook or some media
uploads images that didn't
see that camera before.
We had some, so there was
somebody just uploaded
this picture, and
we're getting all that.
So looking at a
little closer, there's
actually lots of components
which are in my other works.
I feel that there will be an
increasing cross pollanization
between the two.
Also, I am having
my first one person
show in the modern
museum of Addis Ababa.
Had I not been
involved with this,
I would not have
met these people.
One of our great retailers
in Dakar, Senegal,
she also has a gallery.
So in an odd way, they're
not really very often,
but sometimes there
is this situation.
And yes, so for me, I don't
shift between the two.
But it's interesting.
And maybe also
something that I'm just
trying to understand and
learn is that I suddenly
have more contact
with politicians,
the type of decisions makers
who are sort of in the policy
world, the NGOs, the
UN, the kind of groups
who are working with
awareness on energy related,
health related.
And it's very interesting.
This year I went to Davos,
where we met, Nadia,
and so in a very
interesting way,
I can always look at
people, and I could say--
so they asked me,
what are you doing?
So a very Davos-ian
kind of question.
What do you do?
And I could say I'm
an artist, or I could
say I'm in the energy sector.
Or I could say I'm in
the bottom of pyramid
economical sort of development,
or something like this.
So it's very interesting.
And I love this kind of
relativity of what you do,
especially if what
one-- sometimes
if you say I'm an artist,
people just go oh no.
And you know, sometimes
it's also better
not to say it's a work of
art because then people say,
oh yeah, I see.
It's a work of art.
Nice.
But yeah, I'm
learning a lot more
than I used to only working in
the more conventional museums.
That's for sure.
All right.
So I think on that important
note, we're at 6:30,
and I know you have to
be at Media Labs by 7,
and I want people to meet
you in person as well.
So we will bring this
session to a close.
And I will note that
one thing that's
really important for all of
us who are working at the Data
Center for Creating Solutions
for Resource Constrained
Markets is to remember that
this is all, in some ways,
about happiness.
If we did it right, if
we met the human needs,
I think a behavior
that we are engineering
for is indeed happiness.
And I hope we remember that
going out of this session.
So thank you so much for
your generously spending
so much time with us.
No, thank you.
Please come back,
and we would love
to show you what
we've come up with,
and get your thoughts on it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]